hey guys so we just watch the show guys
Ryan right here Jerry we're gonna we
already did we watch the trailer for
x-men apocalypse and we're gonna review
it x-men apocalypse I already see that
this movie is getting a lot of backlash
from the trailer is it yeah even Tyrone
Magnus didn't like the trailer okay why
why didn't he like the truth
I remember it's not a big fan of Bryan
Singer to begin with one thing that I
really like their doing is like granted
yes we have not read the comics
okay of apocalypse already that's gonna
upset some of you for some reason like
you shouldn't even be talking about it
it's a [ __ ] movie trailer utility look
like it or not everybody gets to see a
movie yeah
we're bringing that perspective hey you
know maybe the guy who hasn't read the
comics is on the fence about this yeah I
could help perhaps with that yeah and I
think apocalypse like just from a movie
standpoint of how they're promoting him
looks wonderful
he seems intimidating he seems like he
has like every [ __ ] power there is
they're certainly building him up to be
intimidating scary and capable of
destroying the whole world and not just
like a part of the country yeah you know
just a freaking villain that has sort of
a mythic origin like that actually makes
it bigger than yeah you know bigger than
life a little bit and that's scarier and
one thing is I felt like Days of Future
past the way that was being promoted was
like look at the huge cast we have
assembled we got all your favorite x-men
in one movie you know what it's going
like to make up for [ __ ] it up we're
giving you everything Days of Future
past I think was a great setup for x-men
apocalypse because what I loved about
the trailer was it wasn't like look at
apocalypse as powers throughout the
whole [ __ ] trailer like we're mainly
just gonna show you destruction shots
yeah it's really shots of the characters
and you see how it's going to affect
them on a much more personal level one
having this trailer is also just them
like doing research yeah you know so so
it almost looks like a not in the way
that the da Vinci Code is silly but like
you know it looks like it has this sort
of davinci code style thriller but like
cooler perhaps better yeah exactly
exactly if an x-men movie was also like
a Da Vinci Code because they were
working out this guy who's like all of
the major you know like religions and
beliefs really based on him it's going
down that rabbit hole as far as
marketing goes I get what they're doing
with Jennifer Lawrence like really good
like I mean a it's like it feels hunger
game ish it's like I deserve it this is
a mystique to me you know yeah yeah I
mean that's that's kind of what I'm
worried about with her in these kinds of
movies we get a lot of that kind of
character in these movies that is like
dour all the time and always looks on
the verge of tears and is like a martyr
for their society and I just hope that
they keep at least some life in that
character I'm hoping that cuz I you know
like she's it's not bad which is when
they give for these roles where she kind
of just has to look like she's about to
cry the whole time like I want to see
something more I know you're I know you
have more in your toolbox what I'm
worried they'll do is put so much focus
on her because she's like the [ __ ]
superstar of this movie I'm hoping that
they don't just put too much on her
because there's other mutants that I
find more interesting than her one thing
I like to is if they're really promoting
a villain and this villain is the first
villain in the x-men franchise of the
movies where they're like we're gonna
provoke the [ __ ] out of the villain you
know like make him really scary like
magneto was always like that he was a
bad guy but even like the primary
villains of the movies they never quite
promoted that like no one really knew
like what Kevin Bacon was gonna be like
an x-men first class until they saw the
film well and and I guess so many of the
other movies sort of focus on like
things going on within the x-men and
like you know it's trying to get so many
people to work together and like you
know how their organization is perhaps
being attacked or destroyed and so it's
always more about the struggle of the
x-men that it is like oh we're doing
this villain now and you know and it
feels like a thriller like a suspenseful
apocalyptic thriller you can count on
the x-men movies to be fairly serious
for the most part you know there's a
there's always a dash of humor here and
there but it's usually it's primarily a
serious film and I feel like you know we
got the age of Ultron epicness
with the Avengers yeah but that was a
lot more humorous and more fun and I
feel like this one will provide that
more serious dark heavy epic vibe that I
feel like the x-men movies could really
like I like how the x-men movies have
expanded into a much bigger universe now
we got the time-travel and then now we
have this like the first mutant you know
like yeah getting bigger
like I like where they're taking the
franchise aesthetically you know because
x-men is a different Studios movie and
they have different creative behind it
like I've always there's something I've
always kind of liked about the x-men
films because they feel a little bit
different from the others yeah hero
films they might have my favorite
balance of tones there because the x-men
films on occasion would will hint it
something deeper think about this movie
is like the problem with superhero
movies now is every movie has to try and
convince you that this time though this
is the highest the stamps have ever been
and they struggle which is why we have
you know less than memorable villains in
a lot of these movies lately and this
movie is the first trailer I've seen in
a while where I'm like yeah I think this
could be the most intense adventure yet
like especially if I was a little
worried that this like I know he's not
but I'm a little worried this guy's
gonna destroy the world exactly you know
it's just the trailer and I'm already
like how will they beat this guy yeah
it's like you really want to see how
they pay this off because it's got to be
some things like I can't figure it out
at all how they're gonna beat him
Wolverine stabs him in the back of the
neck just like no it's like a lot of
these a lot of movies I'll have that
where they're like it's this big
all-powerful villain and then when it
comes time to be like but how do we
defeat him the answer is just like stun
him a lot and punch him yeah you know
it's like maybe this will require some
actual ingenuity they did that with
Fantastic Four did they really they just
punch him few times does the trick this
looks like it could at least you know
live up to that level of like oh my god
and I'm intrigued to see the story of
Jean Grey and I'm and most importantly
I'm intrigued to see the story of how
Charles Xavier became bald
that was my favorite moment when they
were like
how he becomes both I'm bummed I like
his hair I like his hair too I liked it
when he had hair and a beard you know
this kind of weird bald huh yeah
no one could quite pull it off like
Patrick Stewart well and partly because
like most people got to know Patrick's
there are a lot of people Lee stories
gots no petrol when it was already bald
so it's like you don't have to make the
update where's like if you associate a
guy with having hair and then he shows
up bald you're like oh [ __ ] anyway guys
listen if you're new to this chanel you
can climb this button you can subscribe
you to this button by subscribing to the
real rejects the Jerry has a playlist on
this channel reasons to Jerry de casa
dos I do podcast hosted by Jerry I will
be guest starring on there soon so keep
a lookout for that listen follow us on
our social networks because if we get
enough followers we can get product
placement for things such as condoms
we need condoms Jerry why why we need
really dangerous what is we need condoms
you know what we're about to do okay
I know no you thought I could go a whole
video without making a perverted joke
guess what I hadn't even realized it's a
natural about anal sex
I'm not having anal sex with you yes you
are we're having this straight it was
either break contact or keep it straight